Why Olympians Bite Their Medals SaveChanges
applied
According to four time Olympic medalist Summer
Sanders, mainly because the photographers
incessantly ask them to until they do it,
usually at the end of the podium photo shoot
sessions.
The tradition probably stems from the age
old practice of testing whether something
was really solid gold or not by biting it.
Gold is a very soft metal, at least softer
than tooth enamel, and if it’s fairly pure,
you should be able to leave some teeth marks
in it by biting it.
The practice of biting precious metals also
allowed people to see if perhaps the gold
object was really just gold plated, with something
like lead at the center.
If so, the gold plating could be scraped off
with your teeth and, given the often bitten
gold coins weren’t that thick, the plating
tended to be fairly thin, so you didn’t
have to bite too hard to discover whether
it was relatively pure gold or not.
Obviously Olympic gold medals today are not
made of solid gold (not since 1912, though
they do have 24k gold plating).
Rather, the gold medals are made mostly of
sterling silver.
But were you to actually bite down on the
gold plated silver Olympic medal, you should
be able to make a dent as silver is also softer
than tooth enamel, but harder than gold.
Using Mohs mineral hardness scale, we see
that tooth enamel is rated at a 5, while gold
is rated at around 2.5 and silver at a 2.7-ish.
Tooth enamel is also higher on the scale than
copper, which the “bronze” Olympic medals
are mostly made of, so it’s possible to
make teeth marks on those too.
Mohs hardness scale is a relative hardness
scale created by German geologist Friedrich
Mohs in 1812, rating things based on scratching
one material against another, the one that
makes a mark on the other is rated as harder.
If both scratch each other, they are considered
to be the same hardness.
For reference, glass is rated at 5.5 and tooth
enamel is actually slightly higher than steel
or platinum (at 4-4.5).
(Note: just because something is only slightly
higher on this particularly scale than something
else doesn’t necessarily mean it’s only
slightly harder.
For instance, diamonds are rated at a 10,
while corundum is rated at 9, but diamonds
are 4 times as hard as corundum.
Further, corundum is twice as hard as topaz,
which is rated at an 8.)
Despite the fact that none of the athletes
are actually trying to make marks on their
medals or checking for authenticity, the tradition
with Olympians has endured and photographers
simply won’t let it die as it makes a more
interesting, “playful” shot over an Olympic
medalist simply holding their medal up next
to their faces or
the like.